العوضي يتحدث عن علاقته بياسمين عبد
العزيز بعد الانفصال اتهامات متبادله بين
ريهام سعيد ونادر صعب بعد مزاعم تشويهه
لوجهها وثائقي عن اليسا الرحله 404 انطلقت
اخيرا وناسي في العلا اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع انا وياسمين حاله خاصه جدا انا
حبيتها عشان بن ت اصول وياسمين في تاصيله
ا حتى واحنا مطلقين لا في بنا احترام وفي
بنا عص هكذا تحدث الفنان المصري احمد
العوضي عن الفنانه المصريه ياسمين عبد
العزيز في اول مداخله اعلاميه له بعد
اعلان انفصالهما الذي اثار ضجه كبيره على
منصات التواصل في مصر والعالم العربي
مؤخرا وجاء كلام العوضي عن ياسمين لبرنامج
يحدث في مصر خلال مكالمه هاتفيه طمان فيها
محبيه بعد الوعك الصحيه التي تعرض لها في
موقع تصوير مسلسل حق عرب واكد العوضي ان
ياسمين زارته في الم المستشفى فور وصوله
اليها وانها لم تتركه
للحظه وفي تطور صحيا اخر اثار الكثير من
الجدل هذا الاسبوع علق جراح التجميل
اللبناني نادر صعب على مزاعم الاعلاميه
والممثله المصريه ريهام سعيد بتشويه وجهها
بعد عمليه شد وجه اجراها لها منذ عام
تقريبا ورد نادر بنشره فيديو عبر حسابه
الرسمي على انستغرام يظهر لقطات لوجه
ريهام قبل وبعد العمليه واعلن في بيان انه
بصدد رفع دعوه قضائيه في مصر ولبنان
بتهمتي المساس بالسمعه والتشهير والحاق
الضرر بحسب نص البيان الذي نشره عبر
حساباته الرسميه على مواقع التواصل من
جهتها نشرت ريهام سعيد عده مقاطع فيديو
تسعى من خلالها لتاكيد مزاعمها بتشويه
نادر صعب لوجهها جراء
العمليه مصممه ان اي حد يغلط يتحاسب عايز
تشوف
التشويه اهو التشويه انتم شايفين ان ده
بروفيل ممثله مثلا لو انا فكرت امثل هو
سعيد بنتيجه
العمليه ايه رايكم انا حقي هاخده بالقانون
بس انا مستنداتي وشي مش هبرك حاجه
خالص ومن لقطات وجه الاعلاميه المصريه
المثيره للجدل ريهام سعيد الى لقطات اكثر
قربا عن كواليس حياه احدى ابرز المشاهير
العرب حيث عرضت منصه نتفليكس وثائقيا عن
لي تتحدث فيه النجمه اللبنانيه الملقبه
بملكه الاحساس عن محطات من حياتها منذ
بدايات مسيرتها الفنيه والخيبات التي
تعرضت لها والتنمر الذي واجهته مع كل نجاح
حققته لما الانسان يعرفني على حقيقه بيعرف
انه انا مني هيك واستبقت اليسا العرض
بفيديو نشرته عبر حساباتها الرسميه على
منصات التواصل دعت فيه جمهورها للمشاهده
وتحدثت عن دوافعها لفتح نافذه على حياتها
من خلال هذا الوثائق
اول مره بعمل شيء ما بيكون هدفي انه اوصل
حالي باجمل صوره هالمره كان الهدف وصل
صورتي كامله تجاربه كلها وحقيقه مثل ما
هي وعلى سيره الافلام تستعد النجمه
المصريه منى زكي اخيرا لانطلاقه عرض فيلم
الرحله 404 في دور السينما المصريه
والعربيه وهو من تاليف محمد رجاء واخراج
هاني خليفه الفيلم كان يحمل اسم القاهره
مكه تم سحبه من الدوره الثانيه لمهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي بسبب اعتراضات
رقابيه مصريه وابدت منى زكي حماسه كبيره
لانطلاقه عروض الفيلم متوجهه بالشكر
لزملائها من ابطاله
[موسيقى]
وصناعه كان نفسي اقول لك
واقنعك بس انا هسكت واسمعك هتقولي
ايه التاجات الغنائيه الحديثه التي بدات
تلقى رواجا على منصات التواصل كليب اغنيه
امور بسيطه الذي اطلقه الفنان المصري هشام
جمال بالشراكه مع خطيبته الفنانه ليلى
احمد زاهر واعلن هشام ان كليب امور بسيطه
يمثل اول تجربه عربيا وقد تكون عالميا
لصناعه فيديو كليب بالكامل بالذكاء
الاصطناعي وبدون تغيير ملامح وجه المغنين
بحسب قوله واستبق هشام تخمينات المتابعين
بدعوتهم الى عدم الربط بين ما يروه في
الفيديو وبين علاقته مع ليلى في
الحقيقه واخيرا نشرت النجمه اللبنانيه
نانسي عجرم صورا لجوله لها في مدينه العلى
السعوديه وذلك بعد مشاركتها مؤخرا في موسم
الرياض بليله صلاح الشرنوبي وحفل جوي ادز
2024 المبهر والذي لا تزال ادائه تتردد
على منصات التواصل في العالم العربي على
مدى
اسبوع